foreign
[Music]
The Legend of Zelda is no stranger to
floating cities floating palaces and
castles floating anything really it's
been a recurring theme in the series
that spans back decades as such it's no
surprise to see something similar pop up
once again this time in the upcoming
sequel to breath of the wild The Legend
of Zelda tears of the kingdom when the
islands in the sky were first unveiled
many people including myself surmised
that since they were not there in breath
of the wild they must be pieces of
hyrule's surface that have risen up
right I mean it made sense at the time
we saw Hyrule Castle rising up parts of
the great Forest seem to be missing
there's concept art of what is
presumably Death Mountain hovering in
the air not to mention since it features
the exact same Overworld as its
predecessor it would serve as a solid
plot point for radical changes to breath
of the wild surface but no as the
analysis continued in the days following
E3 2021 the islands did not seem to
match any thing we know from the
Overworld the vegetation geography the
architecture it's all completely new and
unfamiliar and in the most recent teaser
footage we are unable to spot
significant changes to hyrule's
geography there's no missing mountains
newly formed Canyons or massive craters
that weren't there before in other words
these islands could not possibly have
originated from the surface at least not
from present-day Hyrule anyway but are
instead a world on its own one that has
apparently existed in the heavens far
above the kingdom for who knows how long
of course the million dollar question is
where do these rock formations come from
if not from Hyrule and why did they
suddenly appear now what happened
between the ending of breath of the Wild
and the beginning of Tears of the
Kingdom that could explain this
phenomena and are they in any way
connected to Sky locales from past
entries it's a great mystery to theorize
about in one of the most burning
questions I personally have about the
story of Tears of the Kingdom hence I
thought it would be fun to go for some
of the history of Hyrule Sky
civilizations and see how they stack up
against the sky world scene in the
upcoming title I will skip locations
from entries that take place outside
Hyrule so no Triforce Heroes while it
does have its own realm in the sky
there's practically no backstory given
about this place and I highly doubt the
history of high Topia will have any
bearing on the events taking place in
tears of the Kingdom so sit back relax
and let us Venture into the clouds don't
forget your parachute though
while the majority of hyrule's
population has been living on the fields
mountains inside forests lakes and
rivers of the Kingdom since ancient
times there are those who have made a
home for themselves in and above the
clouds from Modest villages to
impressive Feats of engineering to
Majestic towers that pierce the heavens
according to their backstories most if
not all of them were built in the
unified timeline so before the timeline
split into three and have existed in the
skies above Hyrule ever since naturally
this raises questions like why didn't we
see any of these floating rocks and
buildings in games like say Ocarina of
Time well I mean we know why it's
because they hadn't thought of these
plot points yet back in 98. however
thanks to Skyward Sword we got an actual
in-universe explanation for it without
having to break the fourth wall it's not
because they are too high up or too
small to see though their altitude may
vary they seem to exist somewhere
between the low to mid-level Cloud layer
which in real life starts around 6500
feet or about two kilometers to put that
into perspective you can see commercial
airliner with the naked eye well above
25
000 feet or about seven and a half
kilometers so realistically speaking a
place like the Palace of winds with its
massive size should be visible to an
observer on ground level but it's not
the explanation given for this phenomena
is one that solves a lot of mysteries
and plot holes in the Zelda series magic
more specifically a magical barrier
which I've talked about plenty in other
videos an invisible border created
thousands of years before the events of
Skyward Sword by goddess hylia at the
end of Skyward Sword there's nothing
that indicates that this barrier has
ceased to exist no cutscene where it
dissipates or anything like that so
there's reason to believe that it's
still up there even after the countless
years that have passed since and breath
of the wild seems to corroborate this
while we don't know its exact placement
in the timeline the game is confirmed to
take place at the very end and here we
can see the dragons departing for the
skies through a vortex-like sky portal
very reminiscent of the Portal's link
creates and travels through in Skyward
Sword which in my opinion is solid proof
that there's still something in place
that separates Heaven and Earth as for
the inner workings of the barrier it's
not explained in great detail but we do
know a few things about it first and
foremost it does not act like a force
field stuff has been able to pass
through it unscathed and can even be
retrieved from the surface by link on
more than one occasion in fact the
father of one of the residents in
skyloft used an old robot he fixed up to
salvage goods from below the clouds long
before the portals were created the
reason why the people themselves don't
Venture below the clouds is because as
the game explains the Loft Wings do not
dare approach the cloud barrier and even
if they did the vast majority of
skyloft's residents have been taught to
believe that nothing exists below the
clouds in short the barrier seems to act
as a sort of one-way mirror as opposed
to a brick wall despite this people have
been aware of the existence of the Sky
Realm and throughout the centuries
civilizations have gained access to it
through various means either by
constructing enormous Towers like the
Tower of winds employ technology like
high-powered cannons to blast their way
up or utilizing powerful magic or
technology to lift their entire home up
into the clouds now before we move on I
have to make one important distinction
although the skies above Hyrule are
sometimes referred to as the heavens or
the Heavenly realm or something of that
nature it is not the heaven as in the
religious sense which is a bit confusing
but the actual Heaven which does in fact
exist in the Zelda Mythos is a place
we've never seen or visited before and
is where the gods are set to reside it's
basically on a completely different
plane of existence and in Ocarina of
Time It's explained that after the
world's creation this is where the three
golden goddesses departed to leaving the
Triforce behind at the point in space
where they cross Dimensions the
locations we'll be discussing today
still occupy the quote-unquote normal
World also referred to as the world of
Light which includes the kingdom of
Hyrule as well however it is implied
that the Sky Realm exists in close
proximity to the heavens and the gods
and is therefore considered to be one of
the most sacred places imaginable in
Shintoism which has been a big
inspiration for the Zelda mythology
since the 90s it is believed that there
exists a bridge that connects the
heavens and the the Earth known as the
ameno ukayashi The Floating Bridge of
Heaven which is believed to exist or
have existed high up in the sky
somewhere and is sometimes equated to a
rainbow another reoccurring theme in
Zelda most notably for today's subject
in four Swords Adventures where Zelda
uses her power to create a bridge in the
realm of the heavens as for the Heavenly
bridge and Shintoism some believe it
collapsed the earth and its remains
formed parts of Kyoto but others suggest
that it survived into modern times and
has remained invisible and intangible to
those who had not purified their hearts
unsurprisingly the idea of purity of
heart has often been equated with Hyrule
Sky Realm as well in Skyward Sword
purification and spiritual growth play a
central role in Minish capits also
declared on more than one occasion that
the world in the sky is only accessible
to those who are pure of heart and in
breath of the wild shamaya claims that
only good kids can see the kingdom in
the sky and the ancient dragons too are
only visible to pure-hearted individuals
which often includes young children it's
likely the main reason why so many
civilizations in Zelda have sought
access to the world above the clouds and
why only a select few succeeded in doing
so they wanted to be closer to their
gods and perhaps even establish some
sort of communication with them even in
games that don't take place in Hyrule we
can see similar attempts by Mortals to
reach the heavens a prime example being
the stone tower in Majora's Mask now for
the people of skyloft their Ascension
was out of pure necessity for the sake
of survival they were essentially
marooned on small outcrops of Hyrule
surface sent into the Sky by their
goddess and over the centuries they
adapted to the new living conditions
after the threat of demise was finally
gone they then relocated back to the
surface leaving their former home in the
sky behind and establishing the kingdom
of Hyrule as we know it just like the
barrier there's no indication that
skyloft and adjacent islands like the
Isle of songs were destroyed or
descended back to Earth by all accounts
they should still be up there waiting to
be rediscovered the only exception of
course being the Isle of the Goddess
which did return to the surface and
reconnected with the Temple of hylia the
massive statue which once towered over
skyloft can even be found inside breath
of the Wild's Forgotten Temple not only
that but it's the only place in Hyrule
where you can find actual depictions of
Loft Wings the very same depictions we
saw in Skyward Sword in fact the last
physical remnants of the world in the
sky found in the era of the wild or at
least that we know of the city in the
sky and the home of the wind tribe from
Minish Cap are a different story however
as opposed to a desperate Escape these
are civilizations who made a conscious
decision to leave the surface behind and
settle in the clouds the biggest
differences between the two are the
methods by which they achieved it and
the motivations behind their departure
the Oka are said to have constructed
their Sky City around the same time the
hylians first came into existence and
did so using highly advanced technology
the likes of which dwarfed any other
race or faction alive back then it's
worth mentioning that most of what we
know about this place and its people is
told to us from the Viewpoint of the
hylians and the hylians alone often
times in the form of old stories and
legends some of which contradict each
other or present more than one
possibility this because comes obvious
when talking to the Hylian researcher
Chad I mean Chad Chad implies that the
history of the aoka and their floating
Capital has been all but lost and are
only now being pieced together through
archaeological discoveries so basically
Shad is a Zelda theorist like me because
of this it's hard to paint an accurate
picture regarding the history and
timeline of the city in the sky and its
construction and localization
differences between the Japanese and
English versions of Twilight Princess
haven't exactly helped for example in
English Shad says that it's believed
that the Oka created the hylians which
is in stark contrast to the Japanese
text where he says that the Oka created
or established the land of Hyrule not
the Hylian people themselves the word
Oka is a western invention as well and
is an obvious play on the word cuckoo
hyrule's equivalent of chickens their
Japanese name is much more literal and
roughly translates to Sky person Sky
people or Sky being historically the
hylians are considered to be the God's
chosen people however the theory goes
that the Oka race was even closer to the
gods than the hylians were after their
departure from the surface the Oka
maintained contact with the kingdom of
Hyrule but only through one chosen
representative known as the messenger to
the heavens who would use an artifact
called the rod of the heavens and a book
capable of translating yoga alphabet
into the Hylian Language by the time of
Twilight Princess the two races have
long since been cut off from each other
and seized all Communications for
reasons unknown hence why knowledge
about the yoka faded into Legend as for
the fate of the city in the sky well we
have no idea the city and its
inhabitants have never been brought up
again in future titles not even in
Skyward Sword which came out five years
after the fact as such we don't know if
the city still exists though similar to
skyloft there's nothing that indicates
that it doesn't so presumably it too
might still be out there somewhere
hidden amongst the clouds
lastly we have the realm of the heavens
the only area to make an appearance in
more than one Zelda game three to be
exact Minish Cap four Swords and four
Swords Adventures it's a bit of a shame
that four Swords adventure's timeline
placement is so divisive because the
realm of the heavens is one of the most
historically Rich locations in the
series It's actually an umbrella term
which comprises three main areas the
Tower of winds the cloud tops and the
Palace of winds the latter of which is
present in all aforementioned titles
Minish Cap tells the story of a tribe
who is similar to the Oka elevated their
entire home into the heavens but as
opposed to Super advanced technology
they instead did so by mastering a
powerful type of magic referred to as
wind magic after they left for the skies
they too stayed in contact with the
hylians back on the surface and one of
the late Kings of Hyrule King Gustav is
said to have been very fond of them
unlike the Oka however the tribe did not
isolate themselves completely and did in
fact travel between their home in the
sky and the kingdom below you can even
spot two of them at the pakori festival
at the beginning of the game prior to
their Ascension they lived in and around
a place called The Fortress of winds
where they kept and watched over one of
four sacred Elements which would later
be obtained by link and used to create
the four sword only the base of the
Fortress remains back on earth and the
section they took into the sky with them
became known as the Palace of wind the
cloud tops is an area situated right
below the palace and is where in Minish
Cap most of the tribe hangs out and have
made a home for themselves it's a pretty
extensive area and as the name suggests
it's mostly just cloud formations with
the only significant architecture being
the tribe's home base the first game to
take place after Minish Gap the original
four Swords only features the Palace of
winds which in this game is called
vati's Palace after the main antagonist
from Minish Cap who also makes a return
here although we never see this
happening in game after vati Broke Free
from his prison he apparently took
control of the palace since it's the
only location we visit in four Swords
there's no appearance nor mention of the
tribe of winds so either vati killed
them when he took control of the area or
perhaps they had long since migrated
back to the surface with who knows in
four zones Adventures which according to
the official timeline takes place close
to the end of the chronology the Palace
of winds makes a return once again as do
the cloud tops though here it's been
renamed to the Dark Cloud due to its
corruption but it's essentially the same
place once again vati is back for a
third time making him the most featured
Zelda antagonist besides Ganon to date
and finally the Tower of winds is
introduced as a new addition and for the
first time the area that makes up the
palace Cloud tops and the upper portions
of the tower are united under a single
name the realm of the heavens seeing as
the tower didn't exist prior to four
Swords Adventures we have to assume that
it was constructed much later in order
to gain easy access to the Palace of
winds which in Minish Cap was extremely
difficult to get to and only reserved
for chosen individuals we don't know why
they wanted access to the Palace but
it's implied that the highlands were at
the Forefront of its construction
because the means to access the tower
under the protection of the most elite
Knights of Hyrule those who are hoping
to see a return of the Palace of winds
and tears of the Kingdom might be
pointed though because during the climax
of the game the two structures collapsed
in on themselves with the tribe of winds
gone and the wind Sorcerer of vati
destroyed the magic that sustained these
historic buildings dissipated and thus
they started to crumble and crash down
to earth granted these events only took
place in the child timeline so if you
want to be technical the Palace of winds
at least should still exist in the other
two branches but I'm not so sure if
Nintendo would bother with the
technicality like that and that covers
the most prominent locations and
civilizations that exist or have existed
in the sky there's one race I left out
so far that being the Minish or the
pcori if you prefer who are said to have
arrived from the sky but unfortunately
we know next to nothing about the world
they came from and haven't seen any of
it say for the inside of a house it's
also confirmed to exist in a separate
Dimension so technically it's not even
part of the Sky Realm above Hyrule so
for now there's not much to say about it
over the years many have made attempts
to find connections between these
different groups and it's admirable just
how meticulous fans have been in their
research but thus far there's no hard
proof that they share any connection
beyond the fact that each resides in the
skies above somewhere and because most
of the games take place ages apart from
each other it's difficult to pinpoint a
clear and comprehensive timeline for all
these buildings and the people who made
them as much as I like to believe that
the okra may have evolved from The Loft
wings or that the tribe of winds from
Minish Cap are related to either skyloft
or the Oka their backstories and the
timeline of events are either too
ambiguous or differ too much for me to
be convinced of an unequivocal
connection my personal belief is that
they are all separate civilizations each
with their own history and Origins and
who achieved a similar goal of accessing
the Sky Realm through different methods
and for their own personal reasons it
explains why each of these locations is
so different both in terms of
architecture and the way they are kept
suspended in the air and may explain why
the islands and tears of the kingdom are
also unlike anything we've seen in the
series so far whoever built them may
just be yet another disconnected group
who followed in the same footsteps as
the Oka and the tribe of winds people
who chose to leave the surface of Hyrule
in search of a higher purpose while
there's definitely something mystical
and spiritual about these islands
especially with all the shinto-like
structures and Lotus imagery at the same
time there's also hints of a
technology-based culture the man-made
spiers or antennas situated at the
bottom of the rock formations the
strange automata seen in the second
teaser we can even see what looks like a
cable running from one Island to the
next I guess even Sky people need a good
internet connection additionally one of
the antennas or spiers or whatever you
want to call them seems to emit a green
glow from its tip almost like a booster
engine of sorts which could be what's
keeping these islands afloat in that
sense the islands have more in common
with the okas methods of utilizing
technology than it does the more magical
approach as seen with the Palace of
winds and skyloft both of which didn't
require man-made factors to stay
suspended like propellers or boosters
one can also not help but draw parallels
with the sheikah and their technology
yet another group who were able to
elevate massive structures with their
engineering skills skills far beyond
that of the other medieval style races
in high rule the ancient blue energy
that fuels the sheikah technology shares
a lot of similarities with the new green
energy type introduced in tears of the
Kingdom both seem to act like a fuel can
give life to robots is used to conjure
up god-like abilities like time
manipulation and if we look at the logo
of Tears of the Kingdom apparently both
can take on the shape of an energy-based
weapon or lightsaber they're basically
lightsabers I'm not saying the two are
the same but they do exert similar
Behavior and the islands may have been
built on the same principle which if
true means that whoever inhabits or used
to inhabit them may have made similar
technological leaps as the Chica did one
aspect that sets the new islands apart
from any location covered so far is that
they are hinted to be part of a kingdom
we of course have the kingdom part in
the subtitle of the game which many have
suggested maybe referring to the world
in the sky and not the kingdom of Hyrule
but the existence of a so-called Sky
kingdom was actually foreshadowed by one
of the NPCs in breath of the wild none
of the previously mentioned locations
were ever referred to as a kingdom
skyloft was basically just a village
with barely any power structure the city
in the sky is well a city and the oh God
don't seem to have any royalty of their
own and while the wind tribe does have a
leader figure they are no Monarch by any
means now does that mean we won't see
skyloft or the city in the sky at all in
this game well no I mean technically
they have occupied the same space and as
I explained earlier there's no
indication that they cease to exist
after their respective stories in fact I
think it would be a huge missed
opportunity not to include at least one
of these areas perhaps as an abandoned
ruin or dare I say even a dungeon it
would be one of the greatest callbacks
to a pass Zelda location ever we already
saw remnants of the era of Skyward Sword
on the surface in breath of the wild so
if this stuff survived I see very little
reason why skyloft shouldn't have either
now there's one more place I haven't
covered so far which is referred to as a
kingdom on occasion and has some
resemblances to the islands in the sky
as well that being the sacred realm a
mystical place sometimes depicted as a
cluster of floating islands in what
looks like space I mean that's a planet
right there I initially wanted to
include the sacred realm as the fourth
area to talk about in regards to the
history of the Sky Realm however during
my research I came to realize just how
little we actually know and understand
about this place and how confusing and
contradictory the stories about it
really are on some occasions it's
described as a completely separate
Dimension that exists on its own which
means it could have very little to do
with the skies above Hyrule other times
Hyrule itself is referred to as the
sacred realm like in Twilight Princess
in A Link Between Worlds we actually
visit the sacred realm and even have
control over link brief as it may be and
it looks like just a place high up in
the cloud somewhere Zelda even says to
link that they are back home implying
they are back in Hyrule which moments
before Hilda said she would send them to
so is it a different dimension or just a
place in Hyrule somewhere up in the sky
perhaps like I said it's all very
confusing to say the least so instead of
tripling the runtime of this video I've
instead decided decided to make a
separate video dedicated entirely to the
sacred realm in the future so I hope you
look forward to that I'm also happy to
announce that I'll be working on another
tears of the Kingdom Theory which will
be a collaboration video with none other
than sir zeltic himself we don't have a
date scheduled just yet and we're still
bouncing ideas off each other but we're
aiming to get it done before we get new
footage of Tears of the Kingdom so
somewhere around mid to late January I
guess with that said thank you as always
for watching it wasn't much of a
Christmas themed video but happy
holidays either way and I hope you have
a great time celebrating a massive shout
out as always goes to my mods Discord
community and of course my members and
patreons you continue to make this
channel possible I hope to see you all
in the next video this is Dawn signing
off and have a good one
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]